here's an interesting media story
another Fox News reporter has quit so we
had Shepard Smith quitting a few weeks
ago this time it's Catherine Herridge
who certainly much less well-known than
Shep Smith Catherine Herridge known more
for holding up documents in front of the
camera during her reports she has quit
Fox News and what's really funny is that
there are conflicting reports she used
the term facts matter she used it in a
statement that was released by her
outgoing employer Fox News and she used
the term facts matter in a statement by
her new upcoming employer CBS News she's
going from Fox News to CBS News but
what's very interesting is that
depending on which of the two statements
you read the interpretation of facts
matter either can appear to be praised
for Fox News or an attack against Fox
News take a look at the two statements
so the statement released via Fox News
was I have received great personal
satisfaction from mentoring the next
generation of reporters and producers
and sharing my journalistic values that
facts matter and enterprise reporting
will always win the day this one seems
to imply that at Fox News she was able
to share her value that facts matter now
when you look at the CBS News statement
from Catherine Herridge CBS News has
always placed a premium on enterprise
journalism and powerful investigations I
feel privileged to join a team where
facts and storytelling will always
matter which of course the second one's
sort of suggesting that at CBS News
facts always matter but where she's
coming from at Fox News facts did not
always matter which of course we know
now as far as Catherine Harridge is
concerned even if this is her taking a
stand against the propaganda echo
chamber of Fox where facts don't matter
I mean if she's not necessarily saying
it I will and most of you know that
facts do not matter at Fox News I have a
hard time feeling super proud of this
stand that she's taking if it is indeed
what she's doing she's been there for a
very long time nothing has actually
changed now on Fox News where
now it's clearly the right thing to do
if you care about facts to quit but at
some point in the past if you cared
about facts it was okay to be at Fox
News and she's also not a particularly
recognizable face there anyway so I'm
not going to you know make any positive
assessments of what she's doing here but
the interesting story is a broader one
about some of the Fox News departures of
the last couple of years so we had megyn
kelly starting some time back after a
very public sort of dispute with then
candidate Trump we had Shep Smith more
recently and then you know some smaller
contributors like Catherine Herridge who
have just more quietly disappeared from
Fox News but in the end and this is
really the big story Fox is still
crushing the ratings there are some
concerning numbers that I'll tell you
about in a moment but Fox News is still
widely dominating the cable news ratings
now there's an argument to be made that
Fox News is the place for a particular
type of audience and therefore they're
sort of coalescing audiences that on the
other side are kind of split between a
broader variety of news outlets that's
the madeleine mathematical argument but
you can't deny that they're still widely
crushing the ratings the one area where
Fox is not doing so well and this may be
interesting upcoming as we get into the
2020 election adults 25 to 54 are
considered like the important
demographic in the news world sometimes
they're referred to as the demo the
demographic that matters Fox's down five
percent in total primetime viewers this
past October compared to the previous
October of 2018 they're down 13 percent
in total day viewers they are down 25%
in the primetime key demographic that
we're talking about age 25 to 54 and
they are down 27 percent in the total
day demographic of adults 25 to 54 so
Fox is doing well they're beating out
CNN they're beating out MSNBC at all
most if not all times of the day across
the spectrum but they are
having a growing problem with this
important key demographic of adults 25
to 54 now fortunately for them them it
doesn't really matter right they don't
need to be profitable since they have
these rich right-wingers that fund them
and that's going to continue I won't say
in perpetuity because nothing lasts
forever particularly in media but for
the foreseeable future but this also
connects to 2020 and it also connects to
the the growing sort of rift between
Donald Trump and Fox News on the one
hand you have the folks like you know
Sean Hannity and Jeanine Pirro and I
believe Laura Ingraham for the most part
is on the Trump train they are
effectively Trump brown nosers
functioning almost as state media on Fox
News on a daily basis Jeanine Pirro on a
weekly basis I think but then you've got
people like Tucker Carlson who's not
always on the Trump train you have Shep
Smith who certainly wasn't and has now
left and Donald Trump over the last year
or 15 months as we've been talking about
has been more and more frequently
promoting the even crazier alternative
to Fox News Oh a N or oann one American
news network
so this is going to be an interesting
media narrative heading into 2020 now
remember in 2016 really 2015 when fox
news was not behind Donald Trump they
were not behind Trump in a less overtly
problematic way for the right because
there were all sorts of more
establishment Republicans that they
could support or be behind Ted Cruz or
Jeb Bush or whoever until eventually
they got behind Donald Trump as it
became clear he was going to be the
nominee this time there is less sort of
plausible reasoning for Fox News a
right-wing echo chamber not to be behind
Trump because there is at least that's
of yet no serious primary challenger to
Donald Trump and it doesn't appear that
there's going to be one so the
circumstances would be far different if
Fox were not to be wholly behind Trump
as we get into the 2020 election I
expect they will be but I think there
might still be some interesting drama to
be seen let me know what you think about
all of this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and another reminder twitch
livestreams are back I did one on Sunday
night
there will be one or two more upcoming
this week and you can catch those at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman